the Pope has urged an end to fighting in
Syria during his annual Christmas
address at the Vatican the pontiff said
far too much blood has been spilled
during the conflict and encouraged the
international community to seek a
solution with me now Abdul Aziz Al masih
who's the co-founder of the Syria
solidarity movement and solidarity with
refugees he's also a refugee himself
having arrived in the UK in 2009 you're
a Muslim yourself but but Christmas is
very much celebrated in Syria isn't it
yes in Syria Christmas is an official
holiday in Aleppo where I come from we
have a big Christian communities and I
still remember every Christmas the
Christmas lights all over the city and
there is like a kind of celebration all
over the country in this holy occasions
we can only imagine what it must be like
what sorts of Christmas people facing or
with it but the fighting being displaced
from their homes I mean what what
conditions that they're having to enjoy
well the the the situation in Syria is
absolutely bad in Aleppo for example
where we have a big Christian community
there has been no Christmas celebration
this year because of the evacuation of
people from from their homes which took
place recently with the indiscriminate
bombardment for hospitals and for
populated residential areas and with the
imposed sieges on known people you know
so there has been absolutely nothing to
to call celebrations in the city people
have been kicked out of their homes now
they are seeking it's somewhere to live
wouldn't Syria we have been displaced
within their home country and
unfortunately and how difficult is that
going to be because you've got children
uprooted from their homes that they
probably haven't been educated for a
fair while because of the the conflict
how how easy is it going to be to lay
down new roots I don't feel safe it is
absolutely ho
especially with the response of the
international community towards the
conflict in Syria and towards the
refugee crisis as well like in Syria in
March the conflict with internet 66 year
and that means people in an apple and in
many opposition-held areas children
haven't been able to go to schools and
this is a really problem for us and for
the future of Syria and if you look at
the response of the international
community towards the Syria crisis it
has been absolutely shameful I mean the
the shame of the international community
continues in Syria and if you look at
the refugees who who managed to get out
of Syria and came to Europe we have like
tens of thousands of refugees stranded
in Europe and including many miners who
are an easy target for traffickers and
and criminals and the UK government and
the European government failed to to to
you know to find a solution for such a
crisis so yes we have a dictatorial
regime in Syria carrying out massacres
against the Syrian people with the help
of the Russians and the Iranians and
other sectarian militias and then you
have this part of the international
community and you have the DVD the
shameful response of the European
nations to other future crises and you
speak from firsthand experience being
refugee yourself what is your story well
I came to the UK before the crisis I
came as a student and when the Syrian
Revolution started back in 2011 I was
inspired by the Arab Spring and I know
we had a dictatorial regime in Syria so
I participated in a peaceful
demonstrations against the Syrian regime
outside the Syrian embassy here in
London and because of my activism my
political activism against the Syrian
regime
my passport was expired and my visa was
expired and they couldn't renew them
because of my political activism because
of that I had no choice but to clear for
asylum like being a refugee doesn't feel
great
to be honest with you but desolate
people and the situation make different
decisions and I am glad I had that right
in that time because if I didn't have
the right to clear for asylum I wouldn't
be able to get a travel document and
then it referred to Turkey four years
later to be reunited with my family I
remember when I left Syria my little
brother was just like you know like
really little and after four years he
was a gonna burn your scarf is very
festive but it does have another meaning
doesn't it yes this is we call the
freedom scarf it is this you know
revolution flag and it is the
independence flag of Syria and you know
under this flag so many people
sacrificed their lives and and paid a
very heavy price for our freedom and for
our dignity to fight both the totality
of a dictatorial regime and the
fanatical ideology of Isis it is the
scene revolution I'm sure your hope for
2017 is a pace thank you very much for
coming in to speak to us Abdullah sales
are mushy